hello welcome to the lobby game spots
weekly hangout every tuesday at 2pm
pacific right here on gamespot.com how
you doing i'm your host donnie dwyer
joined by mr justin haywald how you
doing howdy danny and scott weatherworks
here hello sir welcome to the team
welcome to gamespot welcome to the lobby
my first lobby ever do you like what we
did with the place uh i love that
they're we're surrounded by games i'm
very tempted to just ignore the show and
just go pick games off the show you can
probably pick a couple now don't get too
used to it because we're actually moving
floor in like a couple of weeks time so
yeah we're having a couple weeks too
many shows i started like a week and a
half ago they're like yeah we're moving
it's like okay so my desk is still just
like a clutter of nothing it's great all
this stuff we're going to figure out a
way this concrete wall with all the
signatures on us which you probably
can't see in any of this no it's there
no no totally it's there nobody knows oh
mary's on it mary's on it this whole
concrete situation here we're like just
do not know what to do with that
look at all those we're gonna take some
lovely photographs of it and we'll frame
them we're gonna put them on the wall
yeah i wonder if there's any like
something you can like stick on and like
do you remember do you remember uh
rasterbaiting which is like not as dirty
as it sounds like you know first time on
the show scott this was the thing this
is a big internet thing you remember
this right
yeah uh the same image over multiple
pages out of a traditional eight and a
half by eleven sheet of paper and you
put them all up and then you didn't talk
about masturbating in public oh yeah
yeah no did you do that it kind of knows
exactly what i'm talking about we could
do that i got possible yeah whenever i
saw the baiting part of that it just had
a yeah it has it has a s in an
inappropriate sounding name i like but
it is not inappropriate let's all roster
bait once the show is over i was curious
scott butterworth are you with the the
mrs butterworths no i actually uh
i wrote like a big blog post when i
started it was just like here's who i am
and where i came from and literally the
opening is like yes my mom is mrs
butterworth and that is my real last
name
and there are a lot of great jokes
related to my last name i bet no one's
ever said that to you before uh you know
i've basically heard them all at this
point every now and then i get a new one
and it's really exciting when i hear one
that i genuinely haven't heard before
because there are so many that when
there's a fresh one it's like oh yeah
it's great every time we have a new a
person joined the team when mchardy
joined it was great it was like everyone
suddenly had my hard-ons around the
office
and i gave him a hearty handshake that
works really good you make all kinds of
pirate jokes
right you know i miss it because o'dwyer
is like literally like name a
pomegranate wire it's like it's just
well but there's david
the comedian so you get the dod
there was a daniel o'donnell who is a
terrible singer in ireland which i used
to get a lot but thankfully that has got
angry tweets from all his fans now i
know yeah all those 90 year old grannies
in ireland who love donald donald they
love twitter anyway we've talked a lot
about nonsense since we started let's
talk about video games uh yesterday we
got a brand new announcement courtesy of
ign turkey uh who apparently had an
exclusive who didn't tell anyone
including ubisoft but today we found out
for reals that there is a new ubisoft
game coming next year in fact uh
february 16th uh
early february early february late
early in the year late february okay uh
far cry primal is what's been said this
is a trailer effort at the moment which
apparently has got a bunch of gameplay
uh showing off the game in action uh
justin first of all what do we know
exactly about far cry primal well we we
know that it's a far cry game obviously
i mean when you see the trailer you see
the the gameplay like this is obviously
very clearly a a far cry game you're
going to be exploring you have the kind
of cool melee weapons bow and arrow
spear like the the gameplay definitely
feels reminiscent of the far cry series
and in this game you but you don't have
guns you don't have a lot of the other
mainstays of the the series instead
you're going to be
set during the the ice age you're you're
going to be
looking for and fighting against other
cavemen basically yeah and it's not
clear how that gameplay is going to work
out whether it's going to be a
multiplayer game or whether it's going
to be something like rust or like
completely survival uh not survival
horror but a survival game within that
uh atmosphere but you are going to be
fighting against these guys both for
territory and to you see people taking
down woolly mammoths fighting against
saber-toothed tigers like the the
animals that were alive during that
period and trying to survive and create
your own weapons and
be
in that environment it's interesting
because that whole rust you know the
survival like even minecraft survival
maps and there's a bunch of especially
in the pc spaces a bunch of games first
person games primarily which are about
you know getting equipment building up
um
defenses fighting antagonists like the
forest is a game i played a lot of last
year which is very much like that um but
most of these games tend to be
multiplayer focused because of the very
reason of like creating ai that we're
able to be working teams is quite
difficult but when you look at this
trailer a lot of this looks like it's
single-player linear stuff right
standard far cry what i read in the the
feature that we actually posted on the
site earlier today is that it is
according to the developers they say
it's a single player focused experience
i don't think that you know rules out
multiplayer necessarily it's possible
that there will be a multiplayer
component in addition to any single
player but what i've read so far it is
single player focused and in theory you
are a character who tames the wilderness
right quote from one of the developers
so i have a feeling we're going to be
instead of writing jet skis and
gyrocopters we might be writing mammoths
or saber-two tigers or other era
appropriate animals and shooting humans
and shooting animals and doing all that
good work so let's talk about that then
that's the sort of interesting thing
scott we were talking before we went
live about how far cry is sort of a
mainstay of a first person shooter
it is it's kind of the game that
popularized uh at least in the
mainstream the idea of the open world
shooter which has become sort of
ubiquitous over the past couple of years
but it's very much a game about like
outposts and shooting people with guns
and big explosions so there's a lot of
interest in like this is very much you
know incredibly different to far cry
thematically at least
yeah it'll be interesting to see how
they compensate for the lack of
technology i mean especially given that
far cry 3 and 4 were so vehicle driven i
mean again i just mentioned the
gyrocopter and you had all these you
know uh sea
vehicles commonly known as boats yes uh
like uh jet skis and other things that's
sort of what i meant and trucks and
jeeps like a lot of the games
yeah that's all been around even since
like far cry 2 um yeah so yeah given
that you know
since far cry 1 yeah yeah it'll be
interesting to see um how that impacts
the gameplay i mean in theory you can
you know throw a spear you can you know
i saw you know bows and arrows
apparently in the trailer so they can
sort of compensate for the lack of
automatic weapons in certain ways but
yeah it's just thematically it's going
to be so drastically different it'll be
interesting to see which gameplay
pillars actually carry over and how much
it feels like a far cry game i mean i
think yeah outposts are a really
interesting example i mean that has
become a mainstay of the far cry
experiences you know clearing out
enemies from a particular territory and
claiming it for yourself and it's an
idea that it was even carried over into
assassin's creed you know greater and
greater importance in fact a lot of
carryover between all all of these
series including watchdogs and
everything so yeah like are we going to
have outposts in far cry where you're
like going up to the top of a woolly
mammoth and hitting why and looking
around well i think there's going to be
there has to be some aspect of that some
some part of that gameplay the
interesting thing is if it's not going
to be a multiplayer focused game this is
obviously a game where you are you have
a group like you see the whole cut scene
behind you where you're not just a lone
wolf taking down this woolly mammoth by
yourself you have a group of guys behind
you is are you always going to have this
pc group kind of following behind you
and helping you out taking over these
things it's interesting because we're
looking at the far cry 4 intro here and
like we see a lot of this before a game
like far cry comes out like far cry 3
the story trailer they had was all about
you and your buddies and whatnot and in
both cases all of this stuff got out was
like done and dusted within the first
five ten minutes of the game so i wonder
if a lot of what we're seeing um of
primal as well is you know just the
setup and then eventually you're sort of
left your own devices and it's not as
linear as you think that seems to be the
case again from the article that i was
reading earlier today uh your character
is the last surviving member of his
hunting party
is what i've read yeah um so in theory
yes all of the people you see in the
trailer who you're hunting with are all
gonna be dead well that's going to be a
lot easier to make yes it was true we
saw how difficult it was for valve to
get alex vance to you know play along
for the entire game so i imagine like
three other people will probably be a
bit too much yeah i feel like there will
be some some casualties pretty early on
in that game yeah sounds like it lots of
emotions i imagine yeah so many more all
the emotions uh so i guess uh
prehistoric games are the the new thing
2016 right are there other wait what
pre-story games am i forgetting well arc
okay prehistoric
looking well so the one that i had
mentioned prior to us rolling which i
don't know if you're hinting at but uh
horizon zero dawn which was a hit at e3
and has kind of been pretty dormant
since then as far as i know i haven't
seen much coverage of it um but it has a
similar like you are a hunter fighting
against the wilderness you have you know
bow and arrow and you're sneaking
through the brush against you know
outnumbered or
not outgunned but like out
teeth i don't know when you're fighting
dinosaurs
yeah um and obviously that's like a
post-apocalyptic setting so you have
leftover technology from it from the
modern era and primal will not have that
since it takes place you know the bc era
but still like you can see thematic
similarities again it's there
it has an end of the world kind of vibe
hero or um horizon um so it'll be
interesting to see how similar those two
games end up being but i immediately
thought of horizon when i saw the
trailer for primal yeah very much uh um
i guess in terms of its aesthetics
anyway very similar and also in terms of
the hunting so it's going to be
interesting whether this lands closer to
horizon zero dawn or whether it lands on
the other side just in the rust side of
things where it's very much a game that
is a sandbox it's not actually this
linear sort of storyline thing because
far cry kind of skirts that line right
it's there is a story happening but
really it's sort of like an open world
sandbox for you to [ __ ] about it and
they've said they or they've made it
clear that it's not just going to be
like the other games where you're
finding all these weapons you are going
to be crafting and creating and trying
to discover basically new technology i
mean everything is going to be new
technology but like i don't know if
there's going to be a huge difference
between like using a whale jaw versus or
using a bear jaw versus using a wolf jaw
what if you find a whale yeah
all the weapons you could make out of a
whale you had whales back then you're
going to be literally inventing
everything yeah like you're going to be
the person who made fire yeah you're
going to heal yeah you're going to like
television internet you're just going to
it's like all this knowledge you already
have going into the game i know i want
to play the game where you're playing as
somebody in like prehistoric era with
the mind of somebody from 2015. what if
they're just m night chamber on us what
if this is like the village it took
place in 2015 all along like the game
ends with like you know the characters
from far cry 3 crashing into like wait a
minute and it just turns out it wasn't
prehistoric yeah you like blink and you
see an abstergo logo yeah exactly you're
like no it's all coming together
so the thing that horizon has is that it
does have these huge creatures and
beasts that you're fighting against is
that kind of stuff going to exist in far
cry at all i mean far cry they've
established that this is somewhat
realistic but far cry also takes a lot
of liberties with reality and that's
something that i want to see it's
benefits mostly as well it makes it fun
it makes it exciting and i want to see
dinosaurs
like i know it doesn't like i know that
didn't exist dinosaurs did not exist at
the same time as man but i still want to
take down a tv man if tomb raider one
can get away with it i'm sure uh far cry
can can get away with it this time uh
last question obviously when we see a un
numbered title to a far cry game
immediately comparisons to stuff like
blood dragon comes along do either of
you know if this is going to be full
price do we expect it to be you know
mid-range it's not dlc you know that
i
do i don't think they've been very clear
on the price i mean it's coming out very
soon it's very soon it's
going to be based on far cry 4 obviously
so i think that'll limit what they have
to put into the game that i mean that
doesn't mean it's not going to be a full
experience like a full aaa game does
that mean that they're going to offer it
at a lower price because they were able
to put it out more quickly maybe maybe
not i wouldn't be shocked if it's a
blood dragon kind of situation if it was
like a 40 very substantial standalone
but not a full title given that it isn't
numbered it is coming out very soon and
in fact yeah i mean it leaked sort of a
day early it seemed but the fact that i
mean i hadn't heard anything about this
until yesterday so that's pretty
impressive we made it through con season
and e3 and pax and blah blah blah never
heard a word about it like i mean leaked
early but it's still coming out in about
four months yeah so like i honestly i
don't know what to expect we haven't
really received indication from ubisoft
one one way or the other i mean again
the fact that it's not numbered leads me
to believe that it could be a blood
dragon situation but who knows it could
be a full 60 dollar wide deep experience
all right time will tell we'll have to
find out uh thank you very much uh
justin scott for coming out talking all
about far cry thank you for watching let
us know what you think of far cry primal
are you looking forward to it and i
guess the main question is would you
like it to be a 60 game or would you
like something a little bit smaller like
blood dragon not many games coming out
in february so maybe the former uh for
me let us know in the comments below
we'll be back in a second loads more on
today's episode of the lobby but first
up here's a trailer for wwe 2k16 it's
our boy daniel bryan from dancers
podcast uh here to tell you all about
the video game here we go
oh my god it's happened
the music video games are back justin
they're back scott they're back i heard
finally rock band 4 is out guitar hero
live is out in like two weeks time
something like that yeah these people
were so excited when these were
announced
where are they now well people are kind
of just oh yeah that's cool it's really
strange that like we waited for so long
for anyone to make a move on this and
then they both released within two weeks
of each other
i mean they had to yeah like pre-credits
a very pre-christmas thing do you think
like this type of game you have to get
you have to get it on shelves now get
people aware of it and like those things
are going to take up a lot of shelf
space that was one of the things that
killed it in the first place is that you
have this very expensive thing takes up
a lot of shelf space and that means
other things can't be on store shelves
and a lot of retailers didn't like doing
that yeah rock band 4 out today
yeah guitar live at on october 20th so
both these games have seemingly done a
good job of like ensuring that you can
use old instruments there is access to
back catalog a lot of it as well you put
your finger up immediately
rock band is one that's very compatible
with the previous catalog with previous
instruments guitar hero is a very
different experience like so i wouldn't
say both games rock band is definitely
trying to be a similar game to what it
was historically guitar hero is going in
a completely different direction but we
can discuss that cool all right let's
talk uh with you scott about the review
first of all 7810 that's on gamespot.com
uh what are your main takeaways from
rockbound4 the the biggest takeaway is
that it is it's still rock band uh which
is both good and bad i mean it was it
was actually um pretty difficult for me
because i i'm a huge you know rock band
fan i loved the previous games i played
a you know an embarrassing amount of
rock band 2 both by myself and with
other people and so playing this was
like oh yeah it's it's a lot like rock
band 2 again
which is like well that's an experience
that i loved and that i actually scored
a 10 at a different outlet that i used
to work for
and so but different time and place yeah
and that was that was like you know
rockman two about six maybe even seven
years ago at this point so it was kind
of like well how do i how do i score an
experience that is something that i
still love but has now you know hasn't
changed much in in that in the
intervening period um
and i say rock band 2 and not rock band
3 because rock band 3 you know introduce
the the pro controller and try to be
more of a almost a teaching tool and
this really steps back from that and
goes back to the party game experience
of the first and second game so really i
focus more on two than three for that
reason um and and what i kind of landed
on is you know what it is a great
experience but without more sort of new
ideas and without more content
truthfully uh it was difficult for me to
give it anything higher than a seven
which i'd like to point out is still a
good score i mean on the gamespot scale
seven is good
and and it and it is i mean rock band is
an incredibly thrilling experience it's
something you can share with people i
was very excited to get people to come
play with me when i was reviewing it um
had a great time i just wish that there
had been you know more new ideas more
new content um more stuff to really sink
your teeth into okay let's let's dive
into that then first of all what's the
sort of main progression is it a career
mode are you on the road like you are in
previous rock band games yeah so the
basic setup for the campaign is you are
you know young bands starting out and
growing your career and gradually
playing bigger bigger shows it's
essentially the same premise we've seen
throughout every music game since the
phenomenon started the sort of novel
approach this time is you can choose
between yeah like there's a good example
on screen you can choose a different
path depending on you know what you want
to do you can take you know
you know you can
buy a van and tour the country in a van
or you can get a manager and you'll get
you know more money if you pick a
manager but you have more fans if you
choose a van right it's all these binary
decisions and on these menus it's just
menus yeah i mean that's what kind of
ruined it for me i mean it's an
interesting idea i like the idea that
you're making choices but one the
choices basically boil down to which
costume items you unlock that's all it
really means if you're going to get
items either way your choices dictates
which ones you get and second the fact
that the story is related entirely
through menu text is just kind of
disappointing i mean in my review i
refer back to loading screens from rock
band 2 and the loading screens are
normally so boring right but in rock
band 2 it would take your custom created
characters and they would show them in
sort of different band related settings
like in a practice space or a train with
their instruments on the subway i
remember
just kind of sense that your band was a
real thing and it was so great it was so
subtle and so relatable without any
dialogue or any real characters beside
your own so it doesn't have any of that
so it just doesn't it's a yeah it just
it just has menu text which to me is
just not as relatable it's not as
immersive and so the whole campaign
structure was just kind of lost on me it
just i i didn't
really get much out of it and it doesn't
ruin the gameplay you can still jump in
and have fun but to be fair nobody plays
rock band for the story and yeah that's
like like i was just saying it doesn't
ruin the gameplay if you're going in
just to rock out with your friends this
doesn't affect that it's just that it
didn't add anything when it really could
have so yeah it feels like a missed
opportunity a lot of time has has passed
since uh the previous game yeah let's
talk about what is perhaps the most
difficult thing to do as a reviewer when
it comes to these games is
these games often times live and die on
how much you enjoy the track list and
that's like such an incredibly
subjective thing like i went in and
played it and it was like two or three
track tracks that i really really wanted
and i go back and like i've owned i
think like maybe almost all of the rock
band guitar hero games at one stage and
the ones that i really really love are
the ones that had like 10 songs that
i've always wanted to play or like i
could get the dlc for it so talk about
that for a little while like what is the
tracklist like in rock band 4 did you
have any experience like pulling in
tracks that you'd already bought in
previous rock band games what was that
all like yeah well we've been testing
all the dlc stuff today actually i'm
hoping to put up a
an faq of sorts
uh within the next you know like
hopefully sometime later today that
covers a lot of those topics but to
speak to the track list
it was a little disappointing i mean you
know you were saying that you would
always look for those tracks that got
you really excited like you couldn't
believe that this was in the game you
couldn't wait to play it i feel like for
a lot of people this list
didn't have too many of those songs it
had a lot of sort of like lesser known
songs from big artists or bands that
nobody had ever really heard of or care
about and so i mean reading comments
ahead of time in any preview of the game
the comments are made like oh the
tracklist sucks this game's gonna be
awful have they almost painted
themselves into a corner with that
though because like the previous games
have had some of the like best yeah
they've used all the good tracks all i
mean like dude there's so much good
music from all time that like there's
there's never not going to be good
tracks but you're right that when it
comes to licensing it can be difficult
you run out of stuff that you can
reasonably acquire after a while and
yeah there are like 2100 dlc tracks from
what they seem to be pulling for is
you've played these games before and now
you're going to be able to transfer
those over to this current game right
yeah which i have you know again we're
experimenting with that but so far i
haven't heard any real negative feedback
from
anybody it seems to be working out okay
and i appreciate harmonix's commitment
to making that possible um but in
defense of the on disk songs because
again so many people were just hating on
that outright i think there are actually
a lot of sort of hidden gems within
there that i found songs that i didn't
expect to love that i either grew to
love the song itself or at the very
least i enjoyed playing it
um sometimes songs that you don't
necessarily listening to have an
interesting hook that can translate
really well to gameplay so i found stuff
to love even within a list that at first
glance doesn't look super strong i have
a spotify playlist of a couple of songs
that i played while just going in there
and having a jam at lunchtime one day
just like there's a couple of ones that
i picked up that yeah
you might be surprised by the stuff that
stands out and yeah i guess the last
sort of question about this is another
sort of difficult aspect of reviewing a
game like this is the cost required to
buy a game like this so give us a sort
of a breakdown of like new instruments
are there packs did you use old
instruments did the new ones work better
like how much is it worth like where do
you feel the value prospect really is in
rock band 4 that's that's another thing
we're working on testing and something
that harmonix and matcats are both
really committed to like they really
wanted to make sure that as many
instruments as possible were compatible
in fact in within the review if you go
to the site there's a link to a madcatz
chart that uh illustrates basically all
of the instruments that should work with
rock band 4 including like guitar hero
and third-party instruments and they do
like most of them seem to be pretty like
compatible it's actually like surprising
how many of them it's
a substantial majority i think is the
way i phrased it in the review and yeah
it does seem to be the bulk of the
instruments actually do work and and
there are new instruments if you want to
go out and if you know if you haven't
hung on your stuff you can go buy the
band in a box um and i know a lot of
people balk at the price tag and it you
know it does seem pretty pricey but you
know i kind of grappled with that when
when writing the review because it's
like man you know do you treat this as a
normal 60 game and actually had a really
interesting conversation with with peter
brown a reviews editor about this and
basically what it came down to is it's
not really up to reviewers to decide the
value of a dollar i mean 250 bucks to
one person is not 250 bucks to another
person really you know depends on the
individual and their income and what
they consider disposable or that 250
isn't actually it's actually 60 because
they own all the instruments exactly or
they don't want to play drums or you
know or they've got a number
yeah like yeah a year from now when all
this stuff is half price anyway yes so
for me that didn't really factor into
the review although it is an important
consideration that again you know we'll
be covered in the frequently asked
questions that i'm putting together and
how all that stuff works and what's
backwards compatible and all that stuff
so that's sort of how i approached that
portion of the review cool 7 out of 10
on gamespot.com justin you looking
forward to playing it at all i am i'm a
little surprised at some of the things
that were taken away like you mentioned
this a little bit in the review and like
it is a great experience when you're
just playing with friends but it feels
like this game is meant to be played
with friends this is no longer a single
player experience both in terms of how
the the progression the the story that
you're going through like yeah sure it's
not that big but it doesn't really give
you that that compelling hook that you
might have had in previous games and the
first thing that i did was like oh i'm
going to play the game by myself i want
to get a little bit better it's been a
while so i'm a little bit rusty i pick
up the guitar i'm like i didn't quite
get that under my fingers let me
practice that oh that there is no
practice mode like oh really
yeah not a practice mode so you you're
going to just get good by playing the
game just kind of more like the original
rock bands the original guitar heroes so
it's not horrible but it's when you've
gotten used to those little touches the
the small things that make it fun to
play and that make you a better player
it feels like those are missing and it's
strange that those were taken out right
let's add one thing to that harmonix has
stated that they're working on adding
content and we should expect you know a
major patch with that's potentially free
that includes new gameplay and maybe
even things like a practice mode by like
december if okay but i didn't really
consider that in the review because
that's more like what rockman will
eventually maybe become not the product
that you can actually go out and buy
today so i i didn't really consider that
but it's you know just something that's
good to know if you are a fan or if you
are considering buying the game in the
future you may get more content cool all
right scott butterberg thank you so much
justin haywald thank you very much
god god damn it
what really
i'm glad he did it so i didn't have to
do any of you guys live on like a like a
lower grand apartment i i do you do yes
because you just moved into us
living out of boxes currently good call
because that means you can play the
drums i just moved into a place that's
like underneath this comedian dude who
he's probably already angry that like
myself my girlfriend's two cats have
fights at like four o'clock in the
morning and make all this noise you're
giving him material it'll be great there
you go yeah yeah maybe i should just
start playing drums the whole set about
his terrible neighbor let's see it works
out uh thanks for coming on uh talking
to us all about rock band really
appreciate it uh thank you guys for
watching uh let us know what you think
rock band have you kept any of your
instruments from guitar hero rock band
you're gonna wait and see what uh guitar
hero live is all about let us know in
the comments below all right we got a
bunch more stuff on today's show star
wars battlefront is out today as oh
sorry the beta is as is metal gear
online so we're going to talk about that
in a second but first of all here's a
trailer for a new transformers game this
transformers
stay on dimensions that's a lego game
different toy property transformers
devastation
i don't plan to do anything i have
already started
autobots we must move quickly sounds
like fun
um
see it you can feed me
i did not see that coming
it's over megatron i will not let you
take my victory away from me
the star wars battlefront beta is live
that game is out uh just about a month
away november 17th and we've got the
whole crew here
justin haywald aaron sampson robert
handlery you're all here to talk about
the star wars battlefield beta mostly
these two though because you guys been
playing all morning aaron sampson first
of all what's in this beta where can you
get it what platforms what can you play
uh it's by it's i think it's it's gonna
be open in two days it's just by invite
right now uh i think anybody who wants
who's gonna be able to get in on the
eighth cool uh it includes hoth
and uh walker assault mode and it
involves sullest drop zone which is
like kind of team death match king of
the hill and there is co-op right yeah
they also have the they also have the
tactics
no one plays that well the game when you
start up the beta the game very clearly
tells you you don't have any gear go get
gear before you play these other modes
okay
they want you to go experience the two
other modes before walkers and it's at
pc and ps4 you guys are playing in the
office right now right yeah is there an
xbox one update as well do we know
haven't gotten codes for it yet okay i
think so i don't know
eventually yeah uh okay so what's most
important then is what you guys think
about it um there's been a lot of chat
in the office this morning about it
seems to be waxing and waning aaron
first of all what do you think you're a
massive battlefield yeah
what do you think about battlefront as a
as a guy who plays a lot of multiplayer
shooters
this thing doesn't seem targeted at me
it's like i feel like the advertising
was targeted at me but it's a very very
simple very casual game like it's got
dead simple unlocks most of the
abilities you can get in like a morning
and they don't do like all that of
different things and each mode is just
really straightforward so like yeah it's
mechanics are solid
but
in terms of gameplay itself like i'm are
kind of already bored
yeah the most important that that it
gets the the basics that it gets the
gameplay down and you can add like this
is the beta you're going to layer on the
more difficult stuff right that's what
we're hoping for i think that's why you
know initial kickoff today was a little
a little boring was because it's just
it's just the same stuff because i mean
rebels and imperial start off or have
the same weapon okay and so it's like
you're firing i mean i guess aaron says
there's kind of like an active reload
with recharging but it's
there isn't really a reload you're just
you know finding a corridor and you're
just choo choo choo choo everyone's
doing the same web there's no like
different classes or weapon loadouts
right from the start no no classes yeah
there's no classes you can buy the
different weapon loadouts it has a
little bit of a card system which is
just your abilities and there's some
customization to it but i don't know
like i i feel like there's there's a
thing where they're solving problems
they created like
the game has a sniper rifle in it like
why do you need a sniper rifle in
battlefront you know the game has
x-wings and tie fighters
but like that's just solving the walker
assault
mode problem like the original movie
right it was just
it was snow speeders versus walkers that
was cool it was fun right but then like
so
yeah you had guys on the ground because
you had the yeah because you had the
assault on the hoth base itself you had
guys defending the base but it feels
like it's kind of expanding that out and
melding them in a way maybe that's not
as true to the movie but that i feel
like it's having that same problem that
the battlefield 3 had where the aerial
fights were just completely disconnected
from what was happening on the ground
and this yeah i i mean i think better
well i'm not gonna go battle three but
like
it's funny like coming in i really uh
was just pissed off with aerials and the
aerial game in this in battlefront
entirely i was like really upset first
off i couldn't even hook up my joystick
get the l out of here yeah that's for pc
i mean that was a huge thing for me
maybe it's you know this is just beta of
course
but
just now a couple hours ago i was
playing and i was in a wing
and i started to get some kills for the
first time aerial kills you know if you
watch all the footage all you see is
this
just people crashing because the aerial
game is just too freaking fast it needs
to be slowed down
drastically because the maps don't seem
that big so you're just kind of speeding
over everything right right there's just
a constant reign of like tie fighters
and a-wings and x-wings falling out of
the sky right maybe people have just
found that to be really effective at
killing it
so it looks and sounds cool though
that's for sure like i will be i'm at
the point now where like i dislike the
air game so much i'll be running up a
trench and i'll see like an x-wing icon
and all like yeah screw it around
can we just reverse this back a little
bit no and we can swing icon okay now
back guys we we were talking about
earlier oh you just walk over it and you
immediately get in there is an
initiation there's a cooldown yeah all
right so you have to it's a pickup and
then you have to turn it off so it's not
like in other battlefield games not to
be constantly comparing it but just what
i know other battlefield games where
jets spawn vehicle spawn and you go to
it and you get in the jet and then you
go up and if you die the chances are you
can respawn back close to the jet and
start again in this one you're like it's
yes or no so in this you pick up icons
that randomly appear yeah it's like it's
like mario kart because why not well i i
would say yes or no i i
it there's a cool down so like
there were times where i was in a tie
fighter i crashed or died however you
want to say and i was able to respawn
and go wreck that same location and pick
up the same icon again okay so there is
that sometimes but the thing about hof
in the walker salt is that it's an
ever-changing map you're following the
walkers to the final destination so
things do change
and
you know for instance and then on the
rebel side like i've gone the a-wing
once and i never saw that icon again but
that seems so strange because then
presumably like one of the things in the
old battlefield games was the people who
wanted to fly those jets
no no they went to go and find them and
get them whereas in this one it seems
like if you're just running around you
could you just wander into one so then
the people who are getting those flying
ships aren't necessarily people who even
want to be playing yeah and so it gets
even more confusing when you have the
hero system added in because the heroes
are not skill based they're also like
mario kart coin pickups so you can just
pick up something in your later they
rotate around so you never know where
they're gonna be so you just run you
grab one it's like oh it can be darth
vader and then it teleports you
somewhere random on the map oh right
okay so it's not even like you can't
just pop it and then be like i'm going
to charge to these stormtroopers you get
teleported then you got to go figure out
where the storm troopers went
and like it just looks stupid so like
okay
like the footage there too there's
things that happen like what's our
favorite doing see ya
he took a knee man he got tired so if
two heroes meet in the middle of the
field right they can lock lightsabers
and there was like this video about how
great that is but like if you think that
through to his logical conclusion if two
heroes are locked together in like a qte
they're all just gonna get shot in the
back all right yeah like they're just
gonna be stuck and they're gonna get
grenaded so like yeah the heroes the
heroes could be completely
removed so that's the one thing i do not
want to see some people who are
listening could say that oh like a lot
of these issues are like nitpicky like
it's the way that mechanic works or how
that feels but the fact that you guys
are like fans of these types of games
fans of star wars and you're not feeling
impassioned and you're not thinking that
this is like a great game that to me
speaks volumes like you're a massive fan
of star wars and this just doesn't do it
for you like you almost you wanted to
but it doesn't yeah that's why i'm like
kind of like so sad is that the more i
play i'm like nah this is great man
listen to that tie fighter
yeah yeah keep going play man play i
mean i'm getting some of that and like
again i was playing as a tie fighter and
i was finally getting some kills you
know there's a whole thing where you
know as a rebel you you uh get the
uplinks to allow y wings to come in to
basically
use the iron cannon on the ata so now
they can be uh hit by ground fire and i
was stopping i know shut up
it was kind of cool because i was
stopping the y wings from half like i
was shooting them down i was
i felt like that was finally useful
because you know as we were saying
earlier like what the hell are these
ships doing up there yeah
but the issue is that the wide ones come
so quick that it's like the aerial game
is just slow the [ __ ] down like why was
he like oh there's warming oh he's out
all right well i didn't do anything
there like well that's what those ships
are i mean that makes sense it just
doesn't make sense for this map like
those are aerial dog fighters right
you can still slow down i don't know but
yes it's just as an initial kickoff for
this beta yeah it's a little
disheartening and it's not really and
you say beta like you've been through
the mill on this like so many times of
popular games like when it's a beta a
month before the game comes out it's not
a beta demo yeah yeah yeah
like rainbow it's funny i just played
rainbow six siege they called that a
beta that was like an alpha like they
they were still like legitimately
working out bugs this is clearly just a
demo to get people in and to be fair
i've been talking to people in this
office who are not huge shooter fans
and like who are willing to let star
wars canon just go out the window yeah
and they enjoy this game because like i
don't know they're not that twitchy of a
person it has a generous aim assist it
has very simple mechanics right so i
think that's their audience like i think
their audience are people who are not
huge shooter fans i totally agree their
audience are are people who are excited
about this upcoming movie star wars
exactly that's coming up in december i
disagree that's crazy i know i think i
think that's what i'm a star wars fan
i've always been a huge star wars fan
and that's why when i see like return of
the jedi
like
luke running across the hoth it pisses
me off it's like
did you just put them in the right
clothes like was it was it that whole
that was that's the argument
put him in the right clothes the
argument was that he wasn't a jedi on
hoth man he was still learning and
railing this one back in
i did an interview with the devs
recently the reason that they did i read
it the reason they did return to the
jedi luke
was because they wanted a jedi who's
more powerful like this was
the version that we saw but it won't be
because some like 12 year old kid is
going to get the power up and then going
to be the jedi so not going to be that
powerful
how do i use luke skywalker it sounds
like they've made the most like this
feels like the like nerf arena blast of
first person shooters it's like this
very basic version it's like it's for
mainstream
gamers or something yeah that audience
that audience is probably out there like
they're gonna like it the audience who
wants to take down a walker with an ipad
version of a quicktime event like when
you put the tow hook on it's like that
is do they
like for some reason you're already
flying it and you can't just keep flying
in circles do you know what this is
so in the snow speeder you get to of
course use the iconic
uh harpoon cable and do and do the laps
around the legs i've seen it in in
lego or not lego dimensions i've seen it
in in every shadow of the empire about
the other toys to life thing disney
infinity yeah
it's like in every star wars game right
by law so yeah
well yeah you got a snow speeder you got
a walker it's gonna happen and in this
case
it's
pretty bad all you did is you get you
approach the walker and the snow speeder
you get the prompt you hit whatever
button
and all it is is now a
game a minigame of keeping the snow
speeder reticule in a gray box and it
fights you on it
it's like not and not all around the box
it's up and down so it's like yeah yeah
get in there and that's it and that's
all it is and then and then it gets a
little smaller oh this is yeah
this is tough so you want the version
where you're actually driving around but
you're already you're already flying it
like you fly it and then you initiate
the tow cable yeah and rather than just
keep flying a one-handed thing i mean
come on that was supposed to be the
hardest thing every shot of the empire
like doing that like that was tough it
sounds like if they've just trimmed this
game down to it's like bare essentials
yeah like cover all star wars bases it's
a very very simple game and again like
if they weren't putting the full
price on it and if they weren't putting
the like the premium concept on top of
it like i would be cool with that like
i've seen plenty of games recently where
i feel like if you just sold it that
it's like 40 or 45 like you'd have a
much larger audience people would have
lower expectations like they wouldn't be
disappointed that you cut out
you know space battles or galactic
conquest or you know i mean it's never
really had a campaign but
yeah the fact you didn't put one in or
yeah but like again like the full price
like premium
it's just it's so simple all right so i
was curious when you're low on health
does it regenerate automatically or do
you have to find a taunt on kill it and
crawl inside
shut up warm up all right that was our
impressions of uh star wars battlefront
uh justin thank you so much
thank you casually play this game uh yes
of course rob thank you so much for
coming on oh thanks talking about this
uh to be more coverage i'm assuming on
gamespot during the week from both you
guys uh on star wars uh but in the
meantime if you get a chance to hop in
the open beta yourself let us know what
you think in the comments below are you
excited does this scratch your star wars
itch does it scratch your battlefield
itch scratch or something
let us know in the comments below all
right we'll be back in a second another
big game came out today or rather
actually came out metal gear online mike
my heart is in the winds to come on tell
us all about that but first of all we
got a sweet announcement trailer for the
witcher 3 hearts of stone
greetings
remember me
we met in white orchard
i helped you find the answer
it seems you need my help again
do you want my help
it's a deal
let me tell you a story
it's about a man worse than most
a man who refuses to pay his debts
well struck witcher but perhaps you'd
care to tell me why you meddled in a
mata not yours
you're immortal
indeed
but it's not what folk imagine
not dying it's not made eternally living
your life to the full
so it's a curse
you must be careful what you wish for
but there are consequences
you need to get into the vault
don't [ __ ] this up
and that trailer way more spoilers in it
than i thought mike mahari
that is not a good trailer show yeah if
we played that like two weeks ago now
yep i think there was like one or two
bits of that that were like we didn't
even talk about it on last week's show
because we thought that was spoilers
tried really hard nothing yeah about it
and they straight up tried really hard
not to write about well now it's all
it's ruined it's out there yeah just
talk about all of it if you didn't watch
that and if you're watching like one of
the
like i don't know break out breakout
things of this
do not watch the wish of three hearts of
stone trailer it was like instead
instead read my review thursday morning
there you go yeah spoiler free spoiler
free review i mean you can just tell all
the stuff that's in that at
eight a.m
he's gonna have such a hard time cutting
out well i'm guessing he's editing the
video uh all spoilers from that because
the witcher 3 review is like the game's
so large that you can just sort of
put in whatever in terms of footage and
like if you can't tell what's spoilery
and what's not yeah but like this like
constrained expansion pack is going to
be like super hard to show that off yeah
i feel bad for him that he's going to
get everything i feel bad for you
why no i don't is it good
uh yeah well i mean i haven't gotten
past the point where we played too we
played about two and a half three hours
yeah uh but yeah it's it's still really
good all right i'm enjoying about that i
bet next week then when the embargo was
up maybe that next week week after that
we'll see we've got other games to talk
about today sweet mike maherty you're on
the yeah you're here on the couch metal
you're online officially out today you
haven't played any today though right
not today no you played a bunch of it
last week yeah i played like six hours
last week at konami before we get into
what you thought of it back then i want
to talk a little bit about what happened
today when our boy josh shaw who is uh
currently running the show he can't come
in here and talk for himself but
apparently there's some crazy like host
migration problems happening where when
the host disconnected from an online
game it like straight up just kill the
game
and that's like some
2008 like online shooter problems right
yeah i mean it's running into some
early problems that you might expect
from a more standard game the the fact
that this is kind of coming much later
in metal gears life is is a little bit
weird that they didn't get that sorted
out a little bit beforehand yeah
i remember the trailers for it was a
call of duty whatever modern warfare 2 i
think it was where they were like look
host migration now whenever that stuff
happens uh so yeah there might be let's
just put a caveat on it there might be
some technical hitches happening online
with metal gear online uh but in terms
of gameplay mike uh what did you think
about uh your time playing it i really
enjoyed it it's
it's like enough of a game on its own a
multiplayer experience but it also takes
the parts i loved about single-player
phantom pain and kind of just injects it
into this competitive arena that's still
very much if you're playing a certain
like certain game mode like cloak and
dagger which is my favorite it's like
elimination but um the attacking team
can only use non-lethal weapons oh wow
yeah and then they have to they get like
permanent octo camo but if the other
team shoots them or like marks one of
them then it'll reveal them all for a
few seconds
but the defending team gets lethal
weapons um it's just this cool dynamic
and then there's a lot of emergent stuff
that comes out of a single player like
i'm sure you've seen a ton in
metal like the phantom yeah and the
phantom pain just whenever you're you
know going into an outpost there's just
always random crap seems to happen that
you're like oh i wonder if i could do
this yeah then it works out and i was
hearing about you and the the fulton
recovery system yeah
talk talk show us a little bit about
that uh so you can like there's cqc and
whatnot in multiplayer as well you know
you run up someone tap r2 as you're
moving to just like throw them like onto
their back or you can hold it and then
interrogate someone by holding l1 and
then if you fill up the meter without
someone else shooting you which like
good scouts good snipers will stop you
you can reveal the entire enemy
team for 10 seconds it'll mark them on
the map for your teammates and then if
you're playing bounty hunter and there's
these so this is um com link right here
it's kind of zones and the attacking
team has to fill up that meter you can
fulton people and it just it just counts
for more points toward you but if bounty
hunter if you're playing bounty hunter
mode which has like these two ticket
pools like respawns yeah you know you
deplete those by killing the other team
but if you actually
fulton someone with a high bounty on
their head it'll return that bounty into
your respawns so if you don't kill them
if you actually like go to the effort of
presumably stunning players on the team
yeah like stunning and then fulfilling
them yeah so say one of the other people
gets 11 kills will say 11 over their
head and you're like the entire other
team is like let's protect that guy so
they don't get those 11 back and then
right here you can see that if you're
fooling someone you have to also kind of
put
not protect them but stop the team from
shooting the balloon
in one particular instance when i was
playing last week
it was myself and one of the other guys
on the other team
and we kept just stunning each other and
trying to fool each other but both our
teams were on opposite sides shooting
both our balloons so it was this endless
loop of just
like someone going up and then dropping
and then stunning the other person and
then that person going up dropping and
then stunning so finally someone just
lobbed the grenade into the middle and
we both died
but it was it's really fun i like it a
lot there's a lot of absurd stuff that
happens just like in that metal gear
fashion
i was i was trying to get this disc and
cloak and dagger the attacking team can
extract these discs to win and i was
about to bring it to the evac zone i
turn a corner and uh
um konami's solution to like a
non-lethal mine is a d-dog plushie
okay yeah i've seen this you get sort of
uh transfixed by it right you squat down
kind of do this like a mused look this
really yeah transfixed look with hearts
over your head and you're because you
stun for like three seconds he's very
cute yeah i agree i don't know if i'd go
and like really inspect it during a
battle bottle yeah yeah so someone round
the corner and shot me in the back and
it was so stupid but in the best way and
i didn't mind at all it's like oh this
feels like metal gear i guess uh
speaking of things that are stupid uh i
hear something about is it eva from
matthew 3 explain this one to me justin
yeah so you can get a tactical advantage
eva of course has a
has an outfit that
is sexy okay in the kujima reveal
slightly revealing more or less
revealing than quiet all right nothing's
as revealing yeah but
one of the things that she can do is if
you want to get a little bit more
maneuverability you can unzip it you
know it's tight your uniform can be very
tight so it gets more maneuverability by
unzipping it what is wrong now let's
move around a little bit more
yeah did you play around i love kojima
but there's like a certain part of his
brain is still like a 12 year old boy
like i've been trying to spend so much
money to get quiet some goddamn clothes
it costs so much research yeah
a jumper quote tactical advantage
unquote oh my gosh and there you go good
to see the casual sexism coming into
malaga online as well so i don't believe
you're actually playing as eva but you
it is it's like i'm assuming it's a
female
maybe the male characters can wear it as
well but it is an outfit or maybe you
can because they actually there is a
bunch of like popular uh characters you
can play so i you can play as snake if
you're on
team snake yeah or you can also play as
ocelot who
he has this like the double revolvers um
if someone near you is marked you can
ricochet bullets off of one that's cool
yeah they're pretty overpowered but you
can turn them off and then snake just
has a really good seat you see the
prosthetic arm like that
can you still is most of the like i know
when you play for like five hours or so
but it's most of like the late game
development stuff from metal gear solid
five in this like is there like rocket
arms that like get blown out from it's
got its own progression system entirely
on its own so there is a lot of the same
stuff the d-dog plushie i believe is
specific to multiplayer um but i didn't
see any prosthetic arms aside from
snakes uh everything else i know you can
get to level 37 your first time through
and then you ascend it's kind of like
prestige
next time through you get to 38 and you
get like a power weapon and then you go
back to the one then go up to 39 the 40
is the cap but you kind of get a new
top level item everything i like that it
actually bumps up the level each time
you prestige actually that's pretty cool
and so this is also completely separate
from the other online mode for metal
gear where you have your base and you're
building that up yeah the forward
operating base stuff god this game is
just like yeah i've played maybe 80
hours so far and like i was talking to
donna gianbaum about like where i am and
he was like oh you've still got like 30
hours left from where i am um talk to us
a little bit about the classes then as
well there's infiltrator scout enforcer
how do they play differently uh the
scout is kind of just you know a sniper
or just longer range they're kind of
back from the action and they also can
you know you
it's a big part of the game to like mock
uh mark people yes and uh the scout you
can get perks that let you mark them
faster because then you reveal them um
they i tried sniping at first it was
really tough just because the you know
there's that bullet travel time in metal
gear which translates into multiplayer
and the action of the characters is very
frenetic yeah they're running a lot yeah
it's the same kind of movement that
snake does in phantom pain um also
there's yeah the enforcer is more of the
tank you can get like heavy armor riot
shields oh cool machine guns if you want
and then the infiltrator which is my
favorite you can get you can equip
camouflage and also they're just faster
um they also work really well if you
don't uh
put as many items in their inventory
because then they don't get weighed down
because that's a big deal for any for
any class the more incumbents yeah the
more attachments and the heavier weapons
and the more like
armor you have it'll you'll get winded
faster wow that's cool yeah so josh this
morning
he sprinted for like five seconds and
stopped and you can hear the character
breathing he's like what the hell is
this like oh and then if you look back
it was probably like a low rating on his
armor but it's a trade-off that you can
just do that on purpose if you're not
going to be doing too much sprinting if
you're a scout it might not matter if
you're going to be kind of camping out
anyway
but yeah each character kind of lends a
different
you know approach to playing which is
really cool it's cool it seems like
there's loads of like really interesting
differences in this that you don't get
in a lot of
modern shooters or online shooters like
most you know we used to play in call of
duty every year or like even games like
destiny which are breaking out in in
terms of other ways like most
multiplayer sort of team multiplayer
whatever is still on the same very
familiar lines but between the game
modes and the type of technology you use
and even sort of stuff like that just
weird idiosyncrasies that exist like
encumbrance and a
multiplayer shooter it it sounds like it
feels like a very different type of
online shooter yeah it is and i i was
actually pleasantly surprised that you
know like metal gear has always been
more of a single player
experience to me and i thought maybe
this would be kind of tacked on and it's
very separate but it's still very fun i
liked it there's a lot of kind of
crazy scenarios i wasn't expecting like
a d-dog plushie or just two people going
up and down balloons and whatnot and
that's only in five hours so who knows
what's gonna happen and that at a time
and fortunately even though this is the
last metal gear that kojim is working on
the next metal gear will still be a
single-player experience because we'll
be playing at a pachinko parlor
exactly
i hear big boss has already been uh
copywritten
big boss erotic pachinko machines right
naturally if uh if konami's solid come
in and he'll he'll unzip his uniform
yeah exactly more comfortable for more
uh better agility you know yeah there
you go and
what if what if they pan up and that is
just snake tactical advantage yeah all
right i'm back on board if that happens
that's pretty good no didn't work
yeah they've got her goggles and
everything that's oh yes very true to
the original ava outfit but i guess
we'll find out pretty soon uh metal gear
online ouch now technically everyone's
rushing to download it on psn which
takes its guard down time although also
on pc of course and everyone else uh
xbox as well there's nobody in the
office playing on xbox i've just
realized
yeah yeah is there anyone in the office
playing andy's playing it for huge stuff
right now for other stuff yeah andy's
just doing it for forza i feel like but
yeah just like all the people playing
here no one's playing on xbox
you play what your friends are on and
when all of our friends are playing on
playstation man i'm playing the witcher
3 on xbox one and it's great i love my
29 frames a second i'm going to play
rock band on xbox because
dlc doesn't transfer over i bought all
of it on twitter
i'm going to do the same thing and the
instruments presumably as well yeah
maybe they don't uh thank you so much
mike marty coming on talking uh telling
us all about metal gear online uh very
much looking forward to playing it uh
let us know if you are thanks very much
for watching today's show folks let us
know what you think about metal gear
online and everything else that happened
on today's show thank you so much for
watching justin haywald as usual thanks
for coming on any big stuff coming up on
gamespot over the next couple days
oh he's having a stroke again
what
ever since he came back from tokyo he
has like two strokes a day yeah yeah
it's the travel the being near the sun
the radiations rastoration the heart
just really doesn't work as well as it
used to that was horrifying
there's a lot of games coming out i
think most everybody in the office is
just kind of focused mike is is double
fisting reviews right now
that's a good i just edward 40 hands
with reviews yes you have to finish this
one it's published
like we literally had to untape his
hands from the like his hands are taped
to controllers right now we let him to
be to come on the lobby but normally he
is both strapped to his desk with a
controller taped in each hand it doesn't
work i have an iv i had to pull it out
for the lobby
any of those you can talk about yeah uh
well hearts of stone will go on thursday
morning at 8 00
am cool pacific and then uh civilization
rising tide oh great the expansion
bucket which that's all done beyond this
part civilization beyond earth rising
tide yes two colons i hated writing that
headline ah
this is cool it's a cool name like
rising tide but yeah to
like emphasize exactly what it is uh
that'll go up like an hour before the
witcher thursday oh wow really yeah okay
you're a busy boy uh yeah justin
obviously it's been a pretty packed news
week early on i guess yesterday was kind
of a an interesting curveball or
yesterday's slash today uh with primal
um anything else happening on the side
over the next couple days i i don't know
too much about what we can talk about
there's some there's some interesting
things coming up that are not just
reviews and some more
stuff before the playstation experience
which you know is going to be a big
thing coming up into in december but
there's still some cool news and cool uh
preview previews and features yeah bunch
of stuff hitting the site is really good
there's a uh that final fantasy article
that alexa wrote yesterday there's
another uh version to that i know mary
and alex are working on a bunch of tomb
raider stuff as well there's even more
of that stuff coming out yeah i'll have
something up from that end of next week
but yeah mary and alexa have just
completely and danny's taking a trip too
he's
special he is oh i am we've got a trip
as well i forgot about that that's next
week i think that is the next week yeah
looking forward to that and also myself
and andy's xcom 2 uh features are going
up today tomorrow and thursday uh
today's one is the history of xcom which
is really fun because i did that video
three years ago and had to like write
this one so it wasn't the complete copy
of the other one but i think it still is
but nobody's noticed uh so yeah loads of
stuff going up on gamespot it is q4
everyone video games are back it's gonna
be a crazy couple of months uh so make
sure you stay tuned to gamespot.com for
all the latest reviews news features and
much more thanks so much for watching
and we'll see you guys next week tpm
pacific right here on gamespot.com see
you then
you